Avant la création elle-même,
Il y avait six singularités.
Forgées en pierres d'infinité
Jour 1
Chris Pratt : C'est notre premier jour, nous sommes à Pinewood, Atlanta et..
et c'est..
c'est plutôt incroyable
Robert Downey Jr : Le premier jour de ce qui promet d'être,
une année "d'amusement filmé"
Tom Holland : Je me rappelle quand je suis allé voir le premier film Avengers avec un de mes meilleurs ami,
et je n'aurais jamais pu imaginer que je serais dans un de ces films, encore en Spider-Man
J'ai l'impression d'être sur le toit du monde,
parce que c'est juste, complètement dingue
Ce que l'on a toujours voulu faire avec Marvel Studios était de construire un univers cinématographique,
c'est de regarder l'ensemble de l'oeuvre
Comme les choses peuvent être reliées, et se croiser à travers les films et les années.
Avengers 'Infinity War' est.. la combinaison de la totalité de l'univers cinématographique Marvel
Qui a débuté en Mai 2008 avec la sortie d'Iron Man 1
Et c'est vraiment une combinaison sans précédent, d'une série de films liés entre eux
ce qui n'avait jamais été fait auparavant.
Et pour nous, la chose importante est de faire en sorte que le tout, s'imbrique ensemble
Nous savons qu'ils vont faire face à Thanos.
Nous l'avons planifié depuis Avengers 1
Comment faire cela d'une façon inattendue qui va opposer les Avengers
à quelqu'un, qui est plus puissant que n'importe lequel de leurs précédents adversaires
Alors qu'ils ne sont absolument pas préparés à lui faire face .
Eh bien... séparez les.
C'est pourquoi nous avons fait 'Civil War',
avant 'Infinity War'.
Quand nous concevions et réalisions 'Civil War', la fin du film était une base pour ce que ces films seraient.
Nous avons toujours eu un sens à cela
Tony ne parle plus à Steve, les Avengers ne sont plus qu'un nom, avec personne n'en faisant partie..
Le monde est vulnérable.
Tony sent une plus grande menace approcher,
et donc, il fait tout ce qui est en son pouvoir
pour protéger la Terre
Thanos nous a montré, pourquoi il est
le plus grand, le meilleur, le pire méchant
que nous n'avons jamais eu.
Et le plus effrayant méchant que les Avengers ai jamais affronté
La plus excitante partie est l'incroyable liste de personnages, tous bien développés.
Et tout cela va crée de façon excitante et explosive, une véritable aventure d'ampleur massive
Vous savez que vous tenez quelque chose avec le studio quand vous avez une idée ou voyez un "concept art"
et que tout le monde dans la pièce dit :
" Allons-y, c'est cool "
Et dans Avengers 'Infinity War', les Avengers vont rencontrer les Gardiens de la Galaxie
En raison de ce que Marvel est, en raison de ce qu'ils ont fait au cours des dix dernières années,
les deux prochains Avengers vont être des événements que personne n'a jamais vu au cinema auparavant
[sous titrage : Sully]